happy birthday mit du wirst heute 26
jahre alt und dazu möchte ich sagen kann
du hast in deinem 26 jahren mehr
geschafft als ich es in 100 schaffen
würde und dafür hast du einen kuchen
verdient und es gibt ein neues format
geburtstagskuchen für den david bridge
welche hobel stress dieses video gehört
dir schrien
ich möchte ganz kurze psychischen für
mein outfit haben und für mein make-up
das ist quasi wenn man schon da wird auf
wunsch bestellt so viel fühlen es nicht
von dieser welt als als manni cash
geblieben
einzig darüber nachgedacht habe was für
eine torte hat denn green day wird an
ihrem geburtstag verdient musste ich
sofort an ihren brasiliens bucket denken
denn sie hat wirklich einen wie eine
runde auflaufform als ich mich jetzt so
verkleidet habe dachte ich auch ja so
sie in kuhle menschen aus das ist
einfach das sieht cool aus ich fühle
mich auch ich hab auch schon david songs
gerade noch gehört damit ich so ein
bisschen in stimmung kommen also falls
sich ein paar zeilen groppe und wo ich
gerade mit euch so schön blau da kann
ich euch erzählen wo ich schon david das
erste mal getroffen habe und das war
2014 als sie ihren youtube kanals frisch
gegründet hat da habe ich sie nochmals
getroffen und eigentlich sollten wir uns
zu ihr und den anderen leuten hinsetzen
aber die mit denen ich da war zu der
zeit haben sich so ein bisschen zu cool
gefühlt um mit denen zu sitzen und jetzt
ärger ich mich sehr darüber vielleicht
wenn für ihn und ich beste freunde
geworden so sieht's aus so steht
manchmal das leben aber jetzt mal einen
kuchen der wird schon mal hier sind so
wirklich für den kuchenteig habe ich
mich bei slams blog bedient und das sind
die zutaten acht eier zwei päckchen
backpulver zwei prisen salz 1 teelöffel
vanille extrakt 200 gramm speisestärke
400 milliliter mineralwasser 400
milliliter öl 400 gramm zucker und 600
gramm mehl um einen guten fluffigen teig
hinzubekommen werden wir erst mal die
eier zucker und vanille extrakt schön
schaumig schlagen und dafür kommt die
kitchenaid wieder mal zum einsatz
erst mal die kitchenaid abstauben weil
ihr so lange keine tore mehr gemacht
habt ich habe eine begrüßung vergessen
hallo leute ich das wieder euren table
willkommen zu einem neuen video oder
heute machen wir schon in davids geburt
herum
jetzt müssen wir alle eier aufschlagen
anders als bei einem biskuitteig machen
wir das ganze rein beim biskuitteig
würde man jetzt eigelb und eiweiß
voneinander trennen und das eiweiß
separat aufschlagen
dadurch bekommt man eine besondere
flüssigkeit aber weil wir uns das hier
nicht zu kompliziert machen wollen dann
ist so ein teelöffel wenn ein extrakt
und david ellis rezept nehme mir
natürlich sallys meinl extra weil wir
profis sind und zeit haben werden jetzt
erstmal frei und den zucker langsam
hinzufügen
fertig das ist sehr gut kommt dass ich
will jetzt nicht einfach nur das ist
sehr sehr schaumig und rheindahlen die
masse und das öl gar nichts nehmen jetzt
vermischen wir unsere trockenen zutaten
werden meinen freund macht die
speisestärke kommen zum mehl hinzu und
zwei prisen salz war natürlich zwei
paaren backpulver und die trockenen
zutaten jetzt natürlich einmal verrühren
jetzt wird's gehört auch langsam stufe
und wir geben stückchenweise die
trockenen zutaten in süß und hoffen
einfach das ist alles nicht überläuft so
jetzt wollen wir das mit der hand rein
weil es ist schon fast voll
das ist eine extrem schwer gemacht das
muss man muss man an der stelle sagen
dadurch noch dass die selter dabei ist
das ist der fluch xd teig den ich jemals
gesehen habe
er ist wieder ein bisschen
runtergegangen aber er ist immer noch
für lo fi sein vater wir füllen den teig
in unser s-form hu und seine erste
ansprache kommt jetzt in den ofen bei
170 grad oberen unterstütze so ungefähr
25 minuten
der andere kommt in der zu einem
kühlschrank die zeit und der alles packt
nutzen wir natürlich und nach jetzt die
garage also die creme die um darüber
kommt für die garage ich mich natürlich
wieder bei sally bedient und dafür
brauchen wir weiße schokolade 600 gramm
und 200 milliliter sahne zuerst
schneiden wir unsere weiße schokolade
klein die ganze vorlage fertig
geschnitten habt sahen erwärmen
dacic
gibt es da jetzt einfach rein auf
mittlerer stufe nerven wenn wir das hier
schön runter gerührt dann solltet ihr
irgendwer so eine schöne die ghana steht
für uns aber auch gleichzeitig als creme
für außen und weil wir ja einen es
machen brauchen wir es farbe ja und das
ist jetzt unsere garage das so zugedeckt
und benutzen wir dann morgen als es soll
ein tag rum stehen
eine stunde später der erste kuchen ist
immer noch im ofen denn wir haben nicht
daran gedacht das ist eine runde dicke
form ist so denke ich hin und keine
springform das bedeutet dass es
mindestens eine stunde braucht also
sehen wir uns morgen wieder wenn alles
abgekühlt ist und wir den kuchen
dekorieren können schuldig da willkommen
zu tag 2 unsere glänzenden backen sind
werde ich gebacken und hull city hat
oder nicht queen tag 2 ich habe sie über
nacht mit frischhaltefolie zugedeckt
damit die auch gut auskühlen können und
frisch bleiben einfach mal den kopf ab
damit sie auch schön gleichmäßig sind es
hat so lange mit dem backen gedauert
viel länger als wir dachten erst durch
gepackt er hat es geschafft den kopf
schmeißen wir nicht weg denn den
brauchen wir gleich noch bekommt nummer
zwei was für ein glänzender perfekter
balboa des ultra saftig 12
wir schneiden mal hier was weg und jetzt
werden die backen verein ist ein
richtiger bruder das kommt jetzt einmal
zur seite
wir nehmen unsere schüssel und den
restlichen kuchen aber wir wollen noch
ein bisschen rücken form also das ist
halt nicht nur zwei pralle backen sind
sondern handelt sich hier mehr
dafür nehmen wir den restlichen kuchen
sehr gut so und dann nehmen wir
natürlich eine größere schüssel war in
der viel zu kleinen schüsse genommen
haben damit wir aus diesem kuchenteig
auch was formen können also der ist
schon ziemlich matschig aber ich kann
schon ein bisschen wandel nicht nur
einzupacken ob wir mit den gewaschenen
picture händen kneten wir das jetzt nur
so ja das perfekte haus kommen jetzt
sieht aus als ob kaka machen würde war
der eine ist ein bisschen größer der
andere hemmnisse mehr runter
das akzeptiere ich ihr seht es oder ihr
seht die werkstoffe jetzt über nacht
fest werden ich habe sie allerdings auf
meine fensterbank gelegt weshalb ich
glaube dass sie ein bisschen zug fest
geworden ist ich traue mich nicht ganz
mein gott so gut wie sie noch nie
hinbekommen perfekt ich finde wir haben
den farbton auch relativ gut getroffen
das ist einfach immer der beste teil das
dekorieren und fertig machen diese
ganzen schritte davor sind einfach nur
nervig aber sie gehören dazu um dann
belohnt zu werden
es ist geil
krieges haider von der bäckerei
[Musik]
ich weiß wie oft man in seinem leben
budy mache mich doch ist der beste bulle
hier gemacht habe bin so happy es
schmeckt so lecker wie es aussieht es
wirklich die perfekte ghana
diese arten so gut erste schicht garages
drauf das sollte jetzt einmal kühl
gestellt werden damit man es danach noch
mal weiterverarbeiten kann also mache
ich das jetzt bis gleich die erste
schicht danach schaut ein bisschen zeit
fest zu werden und ich versuche jetzt
mit ein bisschen wasser und noch mehr
ganache das jetzt glatt zu ziehen diese
seite sieht auf jeden fall schon mega
gut aus da sind einfach nur noch das
perfekt zu glätten ja nie das sieht so
gut aus für die irgendwie weiter
hmm
seid ihr bereit ihr könnt nicht bereit
seien
excuse me ich präsentiere euch den
brasilien backend bitter unterziehen
jetzt kommt die von dose drauf der arsch
muss er nämlich was anhaben da habe ich
eine von der becke geholt und ich die
legen wir jetzt so drüber ich schneide
sie noch zu das ist natürlich eine
hübsche rose wird das sieht aus wie ein
riesen kaugummi schneit oben und um
dieses runde weg seit ihrem fan von von
der ich liebe es ja ein kuchen schön
viel von dort
dieser schöne künstliche zucker
geschmacklos ein bisschen größer sein
also nicht stärken kann man das gut
auseinander wollen
ich muss halt noch mehr abschneiden aber
das tut mir so eine seele weh
so unfassbar dass es klappt
[Musik]
ich hab ja hier noch die tiere
es könnte vielleicht noch so um der
gürtel sei es ein bisschen wie tief das
oam 1 zwischenstand damit dieser hot
pants nicht nur eine hot pants ist
sondern entschlossen das willst du sie
drauf schreiben und dafür habe ich
besorgt silberne ich wollte eigentlich
strasssteine nehmen aber es gibt einfach
keine essbaren straff stein ist und
diamanten nur im riesengroß und da
dachte ich silberne per 1 passen doch
perfekt hier das ist so eine typische
skihose zur kapelle
ich drück dir eindruck dass da rein
passt schon
[Musik]
eine ewigkeit später
ich glaube das war bitter und taxi leute
endlich kann ich euch meine aufzuzeigen
als cash money nach zwei tagen haben wir
es dann auch endlich mal geschafft für
ihn du bist es mir auf jeden fall wert
[Musik]
happy birthday to you
so leute das ist das ist der david
geburtstagskuchen mit entschluss ich
glaube er wird sehr gut schmecken es war
sehr viel arbeit aber ich bin sehr stolz
drauf ich hätte niemals gedacht dass es
mit diesen strass steinchen so gut
funktioniert aber hat es das beweist nun
mal wieder dass ich fast so gut bin wie
sally
das problem ist aber solche torten sind
immer viel zu schön um sie an zu
schneiden aber ich will sie auch
unbedingt probieren deswegen machen wir
es jetzt hier haben wir ein stück ist
eine creme hätte natürlich auch super
dazu gepasst und ein bisschen
geschmacksvielfalt zu geben aber so ein
simpler gucken hat auch was schönes und
jetzt probieren wir mit von don mcleans
geburtstagskuchen so lecker schmeckt
wirklich meine karamell creme
dieser simple gucken mit der weißen
schokoladen danach und ich finde das von
dorn passt auch sehr gut dazu für mich
gibt es gerade nichts besseres
also der ist wirklich köstlich wenn ihr
eine motiv torte machen wollten dann
nehmt dieses grundrezept von sally und
diese garage und ein bisschen von dort
das ist wirklich richtig lecker ich
hoffe euch hat die folge gefallen und
wenn euch jemand weiteres ein feld der
einen geburtstagskuchen von mir verdient
hat dann schreibt ihn gerne in die
kommentare unterstützt dieses video in
dem er einen daumen nach oben gibt und
abonniert meinen kanal wenn ihr das noch
nicht gemacht hat und dass kimi die
glocke und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder smr kanal pc kanal
letztes video oder ein anderes und hier
könnt ihr mich abonnieren auf meine maße
mehrkanal kam übrigens gerade neue
videos also falls sie da mal
vorbeischauen wollte